hey I'm smelling alcohol I know how much
have you consumed tonight like probably
three drink I need to run you through
some tests right now stand facing me
please but I just want you know that I
also have very bad social anxiety you
and me
both okay okay any recent head trauma
traumatic brain injuries anything I need
to know about uh mental yes focus on my
finger please all right I think we
missed I think I talked over as she was
getting out of the car I think we missed
that it's unfortunate it's a good moment
uh as she's getting out of the car she
says I'm an indigenous person
okay uh and then she throws out
non-binary and then she goes back to the
anxiety well again and eventually she
gets arrested because she's obviously
drunk uh which so it's good you know
it's a happy ending at the end